It's International Holocaust Remembrance Day.
And at Auschwitz, survivors of Hitler's Final Solution were among those marking 67 years...
...exactly since the death camps liberation by the Red Army.
The Nazis murdered about one and a half million people at Auschwitz and occupied Poland; most of them were Jews.
Victims of the Holocaust were remembered in Germany's parliament.
Literary critic and Warsaw ghetto survivor Marcel Reich-Ranicki...
...told how Jews there were rounded up and deported in what the Nazis called "relocation".
Now age 91, he said the relocation from Warsaw only had one goal, only had one purpose: death.
And Germany has plenty to think about this Holocaust Remembrance Day.
One survey suggests anti-Semitism remains entrenched in the country.
Another that up to one in five young Germans don't know what happened at Auschwitz.